[музика]
Курсанти вилітають на одне зі своїх
перших бойових завдань у якості пілотів
Дронів сі екіпажі ваших колег яких які з
мами навчаються ми зараз проти них
працюємо шукаємо де вони замаскувалися
шукаємо як замаскувалися знімаємо фото
відео зберем матеріал
14 15 16 чоловік
Юрія війна застала зі сноубордом у
Карпатах до повномасштабного вторгнення
він займався альпінізмом з дрона знімав
на відео гірські походи тепер він навчає
інших фільмувати ворожі позиції яка
висота у вас 6 метрів
він вже десь має бути А он він
знижуйтесь
Я відчуваю що я
залучений залученою боротьбу тобто Я
навчаю людей бути операторами дрону
Дронів керувати
квадрокоптерами перший в своєму житті я
став інструктором І взагалі вчителем у
цій групі і військові які щойно приїхали
з-під бахмута і цивільні які хочуть
отримати нові навички дрони з якими
працюють Курсанти називаються
мультироторними нинішню війну інструктор
Юрій називає наймасштабнішим їхнім
застосуванням в історії перше в такому
обсязі Вони працюють і в них багато сфер
застосування тобто розвідка коригування
вогню в моніторинг проведення бою
скидування дрони Камікадзе
дрони розмінувальники
в Україні працюють близько 20 шкіл
операторів Дронів у цьому навчальному
центрі є кілька курсів цей базовий для
початківців триває лише 5 днів
спершу Курсанти навчаються на
симуляторах тут можна відпрацювати
моторику управління джойстиком на
лекціях пояснюють якісь дроні кращі І що
необхідно для польотів у полі
відпрацьовують тактику вихід на позицію
навчаються працювати з камерою і
взаємодіяти з колегами Хлопці ви мене
випустите Я туда
Дмитро професійний ведучий свят Він
ніколи не служив в армії після
повномасштабного вторгнення чоловік
вступив у добровольче формування
територіальної громади згодом став
командиром загону нині Дмитро повернувся
до Цивільного життя і навчається щоб
бути готовим знову стати у стрій Я
зрозумів що просто автоматник з мене
короткий тому що Ну от не маючи жодного
військового уявлення от просто жодного я
[музика]
користі з мене не так багато а якщо піти
керувати дроном то я розумію що я як
бойова одиниця буду набагато кориснішим
для всього підрозділу і навіть регіону
в іншій групі навчається Олена Швачка з
25-річним стажем жінка виготовляє
весільні вбрання А ще прагне бути
корисною для армії я зрозумію що я не
зможу там десь копати там десь Щось
грузить якісь снаряди правильно але то
що я можу і то що я зможу навчіться
швидко так сталось Що я сюди потрапила
Олена одна з небагатьох жінок на курсі
зізнається навчання дається на легко але
літати їй подобається раніше мені
здавалося
а тепер я розумію наскільки це важливо
наскільки багато тут нюансів які треба в
голові тримати весь час і наскільки це
наскільки це корисно для того щоб
зберегти життя і наскільки це корисно
для того щоб з нього
і Курсанти інструктори порівнюють
управління дроном з керуванням
автомобілем наскільки це складно
перевіряю на собі допомагає ведучий
інструктор Антон злітаємо
головне правил - це камерою від нас Ми
стартуємо камеру від нас та отримуємо
оборон теж камерою від нас щоб ворог не
зміг побачити нас Якщо
зараз ви він не може получити далеко
тому що ми не будемо володіти Далеко це
ваш перший урок
керування схоже на гру на приставці
інструктор підтверджує найкраще виходить
у тих хто полюбляє комп'ютерні ігри Я не
з таких
супер Опа все знижуємо і я його буду
приймати все що вам потрібно зараз лівий
стік вниз і тримайте до опору вниз все
да да
до упору все
якось так
але набагато серйозніше дрони називають
очима армії тож на війні аеророзвідники
одна з пріоритетних цілей для ворога
коли ти живий якщо Ти залишаєшся
залишаєшся живим
ми оцінюємо це так тому що це дуже
небезпечно броне бачать наш ворог крони
- це пристрої які який видає сигнал який
який може полінгувати який може наш
ворог може знайти і це дуже небезпечно
поки групи продовжують тренування
з'являються перші небезпеки
Ну да можемо можемо попитатися але але
ну це так ризиковано під час повітряної
тривоги починають працювати засоби
радіоелектронної боротьби вони плутають
координати безпілотників тож навіть під
час низьких польотів Дрон може
загубитися
інструктори наголошують щодо пріоритетів
найперше зберегти життя на другому місці
виконати місію останнє але не менш
важливе повернути пташку додому дрони по
кілька тисяч доларів за кожен вважають
розхідним матеріалом на війні але Антон
Фролов обурюється коли їх використовують
не за призначенням наприклад аби скинути
гранату на ворожі позиції
це відео коли хтось кудись попав
99 разів він не попав
і за ці 99 разів спроб скинути щось
невдалих Він втратив декілька десятків
Дронів
тому що Дрон знаходиться на небезпечній
висоті коли він це це робить і його
можна збити на початку війни середня
тривалість життя одного дрона складала
3-5 хвилин нині значно більше з квітня
лише ця школа випустила 700
кваліфікованих операторів Дронів у
сучасній війні технології люди які ними
керують відіграють ключову роль